problem 23
mario drives 1500 miles every month
which line plot correctly represents
mario's total miles driven over a period
of six months it's 1500 miles every
month so this is per month so every
month after one month he should drive
1500 miles and that looks pretty good
there so after another month it should
be another 1500 which goes to 3 000
right after two months he should drive
3000 miles so far choice a looks pretty
good so i'm just going to circle that
now let's just verify that the other
ones aren't describing this
so in choice c
it takes him six months to go 1500 miles
that's not what they said they said 1500
miles every month after one month he
only went you know i don't know he only
went like 250 miles or 500 i don't know
he he hardly didn't so this is
definitely not the case
choice b
choice b shows he he started off having
traveled 1500 miles and it never changes
he doesn't travel anymore so it's
definitely not choice b
and then choice d after one month he
travels nine thousand miles which is
completely wrong they said it after per
month he travels 1500 miles it's
definitely not choice d so choice a we
can feel good about
for the next page
next page all right
we have problem 24
the temperature on a mountain peak was 7
degrees fahrenheit
at six pm at six pm by eight pm so two
hours later the temperature had dropped
to zero
degrees fahrenheit if the temperature
continued to drop at the same rate which
is the best estimate of the temperature
at 11 pm so what happened we went from 6
p.m
to 8 p.m
that was two hours right
and our temperature went from seven
degrees
to
zero degrees fahrenheit
so over two hours we dropped seven
degrees or you could say the rate of
droppage of our temperature if you want
to say it that way so you could say you
know seven degrees seven let me write
this way seven degrees
degrees for every two hours
or you can say minus seven degrees for
every two hours we're dropping or that's
the same thing as saying we're going
minus three and a half degrees
or let me write it this way three and a
half degrees per hour that's the rate at
which it dropped from 6 pm to 8 pm minus
3 and a half degrees per hour so they
say what is the best estimate of the
temperature at 11 pm
well 11 pm
is going to be it's going to be another
three hours after 8 pm and if we're
dropping at minus 3 and a half degrees
per hour and we're going to do that for
3 hours we just multiply the two
so you have
do it over here you have minus three
point five
degrees
write this degrees per hour
and then times three hours right that's
how long we're gonna go from 8 p.m to 11
p.m so the hours cancel out if you want
to make sure your units work out but
what what's what's minus three and a
half
times three minus three and a half times
three well let's just write it out so
point
three point five times three i could put
a minus there we'll worry about in a
second five times three is fifteen three
times three is nine plus one is ten
we have one exactly one number behind
the decimal point we have no decimals
here so we have one number behind the
decimal point in our answer and we have
a negative times a positive which is
going to be a negative
so from 8 pm to 11 pm we're going to
drop by 10 and a half degrees now they
say that the temperature was zero at 8
pm so if we drop 10 and a half degrees
from that we're going to be
approximately at 10 degree minus 10
degrees fahrenheit they say what is the
best estimate if they said exactly we
would say oh minus 10 and a half degrees
if you wanted to do this kind of in a
hand you could have done this kind of in
your head if you like but i think it's
nice to say oh we're dropping three and
a half degrees per hour three hours
later it's going to be a little over 10
degrees or 10 and a half degrees that we
dropped from the zero degrees at 8 pm
problem 25
do it in maybe orange
brad bought a six dollar binder and
several packs of paper that cost 60
cents each
if his total was 13 20 how many packs of
paper did brad buy all right well let's
say he bought p packs p packs of paper
so how much did he spend he bought a six
dollar binder so he spent six dollars
plus
60 cents per pack
times the number of packs he bought
right so this is the total six dollars
for the binder plus 60 cents for each of
the packs if you bought 10 packs and you
do 10 times 60 cents per pack so but we
don't know what it is so we just leave
it as p and the total cost was 1320
and 20 cents so we just have to solve
for p how many packs of paper did brad
buy
so if we subtract 6 from both sides of
this equation
do it in blue
to subtract this 6 from both sides you
get
point
6 p maybe i'll write it like this minus
6 plus there and then minus 6 right
there just to show you i'm doing the
same thing to both sides of this
equation this minus 6 and that positive
6 cancel out and so you're just left
with a 0.6 p on the left hand side is
going to be equal to
13.2 or 13.20 minus six dollars you
could write it that way if you like 13
minus six is seven so it's going to be
seven dollars
and 20 cents or 7.2 and then to solve
for p we just divide both sides by .6
so if we divide both sides by point six
point six
and point six the point six is cancel
out on the left hand side so you're just
left with a p
so you're left with do it over here p is
equal to
7.2 right that's 7.2
divided by
0.6
so let's work this out point 6
goes into 7.2
i'll throw in some trailing zeros
now division by decimals this is
sometimes a little bit confusing but you
just have to remember you take the
number that we're dividing into the
other number and you make it into a
whole number so you shift its decimal
point in this case one to the right so
it just becomes a six but since you
shifted its decimal point one to the
right you have to shift this guy's
decimal point one to the right
so it'll go right there so
point six into 7.2 is the same thing as
6 into 72 or you could you know if you
just view this as a fraction you
multiply the top and the bottom by 10
this is the same thing as 72 divided by
6 and that's just exactly what we did
here so 6 goes into 72 well actually
even better six goes into seven one time
one times six is six
and then seven minus six is one bring
down the two six goes into twelve two
times two times six is twelve you get a
zero all zeros left so you get exactly
12 times and if you know your six times
tables you knew that 72 divided by 6 is
12. so p is equal to 12. he bought 12
packs of paper
next problem what is the value of this
thing 3 plus 5 squared divided by 4
minus x plus 1 when x is equal to 7. so
let's write it down when x is equal to
x is equal to 7. so this becomes
plus
5 squared so let me just write it out 5
squared is 25
divided by and so they want us to do a
little bit of order of operations here
so mult so parentheses take are the
dominant role here so this thing 3 plus
25 this is going to be 28. so
parentheses take the dominant role here
so this is going to be
a 28 right there
and so let me write it down you
parentheses are the most important than
exponents
then multiplication and division and if
there's a tie you go left to right and
then you do addition addition and
subtraction so they're clearly trying to
make sure that we understand our order
of operations so let's do the things in
parentheses first so there's 3 plus 5
squared is 3 plus 25 that's a 28 then
you have an x plus 1 they're telling us
that x is 7.
so this is a 7 plus 1 so that's going to
be an 8.
then we do the division before we do the
subtraction
so this becomes 28
let me rewrite it 28 divided by
minus 8
minus 8. and so order of operations we
do this first so 28
divided by 4 is 7 and then we have the 7
minus
that 8
right there which is equal to -1 so that
is choice
b
next problem
problem 27
what is the equation of the graph shown
below so we just have to figure out its
slope and its y-intercept in general
these are all in kind of the classic mx
plus b form right y is equal to mx plus
b where m is the slope b is the y
intercept the slope here
our rise over run for every one we run
we rise up one or every chain for a
change in x of one we have a change in y
of one so slope
is equal to change in y over change in x
or rise over run
we rise by one when we run by one so
it's equal to one over one which is
equal to one so m is equal to one and in
every situation here our slope is one so
that didn't help us so far but then b is
the y-intercept where we intersect the y
axis and you can see just from
inspection that's it
that's at
y is equal to 3. so we look for so b is
3. so this so our equation is going to
be y is equal to 1 times x which is just
x plus the y intercept
of three so y is equal to x plus three
which is right there
let's see no more problems on that page